aujourd'hui je ne veux que de l'amour et
de la marque annonce vidéo est ce que
c'est possible oui c'est possible alors
on a commencé au sujet laurent tu peux
essayer au certaines études et n'espérez
pas que je vais faire un petit peu
attention va démarrer les chéris données
moindre inquiétait ça c'est de la
raquette de bouge pas c'est du très très
bon matériel ça bravo les mecs
allez on y va démarrer isabelle fait un
service nettement c'est pas demain mais
c'est déjà de faire de temps en temps
c'est parti allez c'est parti et on va
de chronométrer après tu vas voir ça il
fait pas d'eux de ce qu'elle fait de
mauvais tours
huawei a dit à quelqu'un
non mais mes toiles à mes toiles
abdallah avait de bons amis et sessions
orales et raymond embauché médias mon
frérot allez vas-y que je te laisse la
balle est contraire au contraire pour
aller vite faut aller vite avant
[Applaudissements]
91 pour l'instant c'est le dr juan
rappelle que les numéros 1 affrontera en
finale on faire gagner trottinette avec
un tour en 5 et indiens normal qu'ils
veulent faire allez on va y aller kelly
est fatigué banimmo si elles sont pas
bien tu as fait de l'argent il y en a
une qui l'agacent il y en a une que la
gastro une qui a mal au dos s'est trouvé
coincé on est basse et batterie bac et
du bassin ouvre les yeux ou les jeux des
jeux les yeux alors laquelle voilà tout
son courage elle est battue il est battu
par émond 90 91 témoins devant ata les
boules à des gangs à l'école jean michel
maire sera mise alors je vous dis s'il
vous plaît la caméra se plaît à vous
toucher comme ça les deux vous aurez la
gastro et une aura toujours mon
[Rires]
attention
hélas hélas pas visé n'a pas misé merci
faux billets dans le mur allait chez
nous et maintien battu de leur moi aussi
il a un look de tennisman
il aime les raquettes croire non bien
combien caméra capte cadence originaux
attention j'y tiens tiens le qualifie
c'est toujours raymond qui est en tête
c'est normal christine kelly mais de là
à les deux maps les bébés voilà à quoi
tu m'épates à tête à tête dessus
jamais la tête de ce symbole de mon
maquillage les bonnes manières ça
calcule la vitesse les mecs on a
complètement oublié quelqu'un tombe à
bobigny donc j les coûts afférents tu
veux le dire évident à 10 descend
pendant que tu nous donnes ratatouille
ou de la raquette à puma qui s'est dit
ça a pas l'air bien à quoi son vol ça
qu'à travers la famille l'internât ces
familles il a raté il a loupé la louper
car c'est remo cérémonie la tête john
gynéco vas-y machine à laver
danuta raquette de lambeaux en août à un
agent haraket el nahda
alors toi luche est ce qu'il a besoin de
tous mais
j'ai d'abord dû tourner silva zizanie
[Rires]
alors elle m'a dit vas-y fais-le sont
tournés vers le bas mais il a mis un bel
esprit vas-y toi fais le sens tournai
fait le tour des cieux alors voilà c'est
l'invité au jour où sera invité dans
l'émission fresque sénia loire jeu deux
volets la saison l'ont alors la finale
c'est donc très bon contrebande est nul
non c'est pas grave tu veux leur faire
sans rien au fait ne sont rien comme ça
pour le trophée le sourire ils sont bien
là ça tourne
vas-y fais-le ce mois ci de le faire
sans rien regarder le pire
bah voilà en fait c'est pas énorme et
mon mieux et ça tourne ça tourne ça
tourne mais attention je mets mon en
deux tirs mon chéri si tu gagnes c'est
toi qui gagnes la trottinette électrique
non non non non et sinon c'est moi qui
la donnerai intelligent mitterrand
tourmente de vente alors on fait une
fois au tournant et une fois sans
tourner et on est on accumule les points
est ce que tu vas commencer tu commences
tu comment en contournant en tournant
commencé sa tournée parce que une fois
que vous tournez vont tourner pendant
cinq minutes pas d'accord oui bon ok
vous
quand on met toutes les chances de son
côté sa tournée il va me déchirer direct
j'ai loupé en plus il ya les 7 8 et 10
féminin c'est vrai les remarques
sexistes sont bien tirés au milieu
raymond quand tu tires sur les côtés ce
pas bon alors magazine lui a perdu quand
je trais consensus très confiance
récemment je me vois pas perdre
moi j'ai tourné trop long et trop tu as
donc la tête à 118 j'ai fait trop de
tout donc ta 118 sur les oeufs a juste
assuré qu'il est quelqu'un assure cyril
aussi six cas ce qu'elle vous assurez
syrienne pas on est dix fois juste avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et avec vos conneries caisse la caisse
il ya des mollahs rageux comme ça que
vous l'avez gagnée tout donc on va
perdre les yeux alors à la bombe et
chérie donc ça alors il ya quelqu'un qui
va gagner une trottinette grâce à mon
rôle est ce que voulait en faire un
dernier quelqu'un est ce que quelqu'un
vous voir maman ce qui fait en dernier
est ce que tu voulais maintenant je fais
un prévôtois castadi restany je me
rappelle que je dis oui il va mettre en
string away genre des banques aba non
barre au milieu ça va on a laissé tomber
cette année c'est quoi la lan dont le
truc c'est que je fais pas km heure de
plus que vous il pense je les avais
juste votre rêve asie votre engagement
d'y aller bastille à sion 20 km heure de
plus passionnantes à récepteurs
nicotiniques à la vache à lait palais le
pape non mais là avec toi mais non mais
tu es fou quoi tu as tu ressenti je suis
fair play je te dis 20 km mardi puisque
twilight est petit ça joue pas donc soit
faire son bien dans son cas mais c'est
bien garde le regard de la gnac il a
déjà cinq nuls
[Applaudissements]